you know just as there's all this
fear-mongering that government is going
to take over every corporation and
government is going to take over every
business or every form of production we
should be scared right now because
corporations have taken over our
government in my opinion we should be
wary of any entity in which both of
those things are combined whether it's
through one way or the other and that's
why the emphasis in democratic socialism
is on democracy and it's not about you
know it it's it's just as much a
transformation about bringing democracy
to the workplace so that we have a say
and that we don't check all of our
rights at the door every time we cross
the threshold into our workplace because
at the end of the day as workers and as
people of society were the ones creating
wealth not a corporate CEO it's not a
CEO that's make that's actually creating
four billion dollars a year
it is the millions of workers in this
country that's creating billions of
dollars of economic productivity a year
and our system should reflect
[Applause]